madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres alors que vous prononcez
devant cette assemblée votre discours de
politique générale il est clair que 2024
sera une année
décisive pour pour notre continent
d'abord avec la tenue d'un scrutin qui
déterminera l'Europe que nous
voulons pour notre pays ensuite alors
que les Jeux Olympiques et paralympiqu
de Paris feront rayonner la France le
monde pour notre avenir enfin puisque
les politiques que nous aurons à voter à
mettre en place dès maintenant
définiront le visage de notre nation
pour les décennies à venir c'est dans ce
contexte plein d'enjeux et de défis que
vous avez été nommé monsieur le Premier
ministre et cette nomination symbolise
pour les députés Renaissance autant une
marque de renouvellement que de
fidélité de fidélité oui à l'égard de
cette majorité parlementaire dont vous
êtes issu
cette majorité qui en 7 ans a créé 2
millions d'emplois et fait de l'objectif
du plein emploi un but atteignable et
non un vœux
pieux cette
majorité cette majorité qui est celle
qui a entamé la réindustrialisation de
notre pays avec l'installation de plus
de 300 nouvelles usines sur notre
territoire celle qui investit dans notre
souveraineté énergétique en relançant
notre filière nucléaire et en
développant les énergies renouvelables
comme jamais auparavant celle qui a
permis un renfoncement des effectifs de
notre police et de notre justice dans
des proportions inédites depuis 30 ans
et redonner à nos armées les moyens
d'assurer leur mission aux quatre coin
du globe c'est cette majorité qui a
accru l'égalité des chances dans le
dédoublement des classes et l'école
inclusive et qui lutte depuis 7 ans
contre les déserts médicaux avec la
suppression
et la libération du temps médical mais
nous devons aller plus loin vous avez
fait Monsieur le Premier Ministre des
annonces fortes devant nous cell qui ont
su protéger nos concitoyens et nos
entreprises lors de la crise du covid-19
comme nous les protégeons encore
aujourd'hui face à l'inflation plus
qu'aucun autre pays
européen cette majorité qui a fait de la
France le premier pays d'Europe en terme
d'investissement tout en la transition
écologique avec la baisse de plus de 4 %
de nos émissions de CO2 en 2023
oui 4% nous sommes dans la
trajectoire celle qui a voté les moyens
de protéger notre souveraineté
alimentaire avec les lois égalim j'y
reviendrai je pourrais multiplier j'y
reviendrai je pourrais multiplier les
exemple de notre action résolue depuis 7
ans pour libérer pour protéger et
transformmer notre
pays Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
vous inscrivez dans notre dans cette
histoire et vous avez désormais avec
votre gouvernement à en écrire une
nouvelle page et vous avez d'emblé voulu
vous inscrire sous la prime sous le
prisme de l'action et du concret c'est
une nécessité tant la politique risque
de mourir de ce paradoxe celui de ne pas
aoser dire les choses d'un côté et de
l'autre d'en dire trop au risque de se
perdre dans le discours au détriment des
actes plus que tout les temps que nous
vivons imposent que nous soyons dans le
faire davantage que dans le dire dans
l'action plutôt que dans
l'incantation Monsieur le Premier
Ministre parce que nous partageons le
même constat nous attendons de vous que
votre action prenne toujours en compte
la réalisation du dernier
kilomètre celui sans lequel il n'est pas
concevable de pouvoir changer réellement
la vie des
Français vos paroles devant cette
assemblée et vos premières décisions
constituent une preuve de l'importance
que vous accordez à cet impératif et il
aura s'incarner dans les nombreux
domaines qui définiront la France de
demain l'un des plus essentiels pour
notre pays premier producteur européen
c'est bien sûr
l'agriculture dans un monde aux échanges
ultra
compétitifs nous devons continuer à
défendre l'excellence des produits
français en imposant les mêmes normes de
qualité aux pays qui veulent importer
leur denrée chez nous les députés
Renaissance veulent ces clauses miroir
pour qu'il soit impossible d'importer
des produits qui ne correspondent pas à
nos normes et nous
saluons et nous saluons votre
détermination à les instaurer dans nos
échanges
commerciaux c'est cette préoccupation
d'une alimentation de qualité qui nous a
posé poussé à déposer une proposition de
loi sur le bien manger qui sera votée
ici dans cette assemblée en mars
prochain mais pour que notre agriculture
prospère il faut avant tout que ceux qui
la font vivre puisse vivre de cette
activité sans craindre le
lendemain pour cela en tant que
législateur nous ne pouvons tolérer que
les lois votées par la représentation
nationale soient contourné voire baffoué
aussi nous saluons votre volonté de
faire respecter par les distributeurs
les transformateurs et les industriels
les lois égalim ainsi que la loi que
nous avons porté pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement des Français en
produits de grandes
consommation nous serons à vos côtés
pour défendre l'agriculture exiger
qu'elle soit rémunéré à sa juste
valeur et nous continuerons dans les
semaines à venir à nous faire le relais
des préoccupations des maréchers des
éleveurs des viticulteurs des céréaliers
de l'ensemble des agriculteurs et des
pêcheurs de nos
territoires pour porter des textes qui
améliorent leur quotidien tel que la
proposition de loi renaissance pour
protéger le mode de vie agricole face au
troubles du voisinage dans cette
perspective nous nous appliquerons à
enrchir toujours plus la future loi
d'orientation agricole et apporter des
mesures qui changeront concrètement et
rapidement la situation de ceux qui nous
nourrissent ce choc des facilités que
nous voulons pour notre agriculture il
doit aussi se faire au bénéfice de
l'ensemble des concitoyens et des
entreprises de notre pays sans oublier
les collectivités
locales la bureaucratie est un poison
lorsqu'il alimente le désordre au lieu
de le
résoudre à la suite de la crise du covid
nous avons commencé à lever certaines
lenteurs à remettre en cause des
procédures sans logique c'est cet élan
qu'il nous faut conserver dans la
nouvelle loi de sa
simplification nous serons évidemment au
rendez-vous pour l'amender et
l'accentuer ce chantier de la
simplification nous permettra ainsi de
modifier profondément la vie de nos
concitoyens tout en maintenant notre
objectif de redressement des finances
publiques la bonne tenue de nos comptes
est un impératif absolu de notre
majorité et nous tiendrons ensemble
monsieur le Premier ministre le
désendettement que nous nous sommes
fixés cette trajectoire que nous sommes
fixés jusqu'en 202
7 plus que tout pour permettre à notre
pays de prospérer il faut vous l'avez
martelé dans votre discours redonner
toute sa pertinence à la valeur
travail d'abord en faisant sorte que le
travail paye et en refusant de laisser
des millions de salariés s'enfoncer dans
la
précarité nous ne pouvons tolérer que
ceux qui respectent notre contrat social
et contribue chaque jour à faire tourner
nos entreprises connaissent les
angoisses des fin de mois cette classe
moyenne qui est le pilier de notre
économie et qui se sent trop souvent la
grande oublié de nos politiques
publiques à cet égard les mesures que
vous avez annoncé ici Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vont dans le bon sens
car le travail doit toujours payer plus
que
l'inactivité ce combat pour le travail
il est au cœur du projet que les députés
Renaissance défendent depuis 7 ans car
il est l'essence même de l'émancipation
de chacun et il sera déterminant pour
améliorer durablement le pouvoir d'achat
des Français qui est leur principale
préoccupation et qui doit donc être la
nôtre en métropole comme en outrem
essentiel aussi dans cette quête
d'émancipation est l'accès pour tous à
un logement or la crise que connaî
actuellement ce secteur impose que nous
apportions des réponses fortes aux
Français
les textes que notre groupe a porté ces
derniers mois qu'il s'agisse de la
proposition contre l'occupation illicite
ou celle sur les meublés touristique
constitue des premières briques nous
plons depuis longtemps pour franchir un
cap un véritable choc de l'offre vous le
savez Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
étiez attendu sur ce sujet vous y avez
répondu par des annonces
fortes un autre impératif un droit
fondamental même c'est le droit à la
sécurité
[Musique]
aucun habitant ne devrait craindre de se
promener dans son quartier aucune femme
devrait craindre de rentrer seule le
soir aucun citoyen ne devrait être
victime d'incivilité voire de violence
dans l'espace
public aucun Français ne devrait
craindre de représaill du simple fait de
sa confession à tous nous devons leur
assurer quel que soit leur lieu de
résidence leur genre ou leur religion
qu'ils puissent vivre en paix dans leur
pays les députés renaissances y
contribueront dès ce printemps avec une
proposition de loi renforçant la réponse
pénale contre les infractions à
caractère raciste ou antisémite et un
autre allongeant la durée de
l'ordonnance de protection pour les
victimes de violence
conjugale j'ai commencé à énumérer les
chantiers de court terme mais je
n'oublie naturellement pas ceux qui ont
vocation à s'inscrire dans le temps long
car ils sont au fondement même de notre
identité parmi eux le premier bien sûr
l'école car c'est auprès des jeunes
générations que se joue notre avenir des
jeunes générations à qui monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez d'emblé dit
que vous vouliez redonner des causes
d'espérance nous ne pouvons qu'y
souscrire pour cela l'école est
primordiale et pour lui redonner toute
sa place nous devons jamais oublier
hésiter à changer ce qui doit l'être à
bousculer les schémas lorsqu'ils sont
imparfaits à donner les moyens à nos
enseignants aux établissements de
valoriser ce qui
fonctionne cet investissement du
politique il faut qu'il se traduise dans
tous les services publics partout sur
les territoires notamment en matière de
santé car la première cause du sentiment
d'abandon de beaucoup c'est le manque
d'accès aux soins je l'ai dit notre
majorité a déjà agi pour inverser la
tendance et comme vous l'avez souligné
dans votre discours il nous faudra
accentuer cet effort nous serons à vos
côtés pour
cela un autre défi de notre temps le
plus grand sans doute c'est le
changement climatique vous avez en
responsabilité Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la planif exposer la
planification
écologique ce sera essentiel pour
promouvoir une écologie de l'innovation
et de solution plutôt qu'une écologie de
l'obligation l'économie l'écologie doit
rimer avec ambition écologie ne doit
jamais rimer avec
décroissance car oui nous ne pouvons
nous ne devons pas abandonner notre
ambition écologique mais celle-ci ne
doit jamais se faire au détriment des
Français il faut aussi redonner aux
citoyens le goût de l'engagement c'est
ce que notre majorité s'emploie à faire
en votant cette semaine la proposition
de loi visant à soutenir l'engagement
bénévole ainsi que la proposition de loi
visant à reconnaître les métiers de la
médiation
sociale votre décision de pérenniser les
cours d'éducation civique à l'école
constitue également un signe
extrêmementcageant de même la
généralisation du SNU que vous venez
d'annoncer ce besoin d'engagement il se
fait aussi sentir dans notre démocratie
cela impose de revaloriser ceux qui la
font vivre il n'est pas concevable que
dans notre pays les élus soient
impunément l'objet d'insulte de de
menace de de violence pour ne pas dire
de
l'inchage servir ses concitoyens au sein
de sa commune de son département de sa
région ou dans cette assemblée ne
devrait jamais faire craindre pour sa
vie ou pour celle de ses proche une
démocratie qui se retourne contre ceux
qui la servent elle se détruit et honte
à ceux qui par leur comportement
outranciers ont pu y compris sur ces
bancs alimenter ses bas
instincts à cet égard la proposition de
loi renforçant la sécurité des élus
locaux sera
salutaire car le retour de l'autorité
passe nécessairement par le respect
envers les institutions et leurs
représentants pour mener à bien toutes
ces entreprises l'esprit de compromis
qui exige la configuration de notre
assemblée apparaît
indispensable je le redis aujourd'hui
devant l'ensemble des groupes de l'arc
républicain ma main et celle des députés
Renaissance est toujours
pour construire des majorités de
projets nous le faisons déjà à travers
plusieurs texte
transpartisan il nous faut accentuer cet
élan mais pour conduire toutes ces
réformes un autre élément consubstantiel
au projet que nous portons depuis 2017
m' paraî
essentiel car Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la France a besoin
d'audaceace pour tenir Leurent qui est
le sien dans le concert des nations et
en Europe d'audace pour préserver l'art
de vivre à la française et faire valoir
ses idéaux face au bouleversement du
monde d'audace pour se réinventer sans
cesse en accord avec son histoire et ses
valeurs et parce que votre action entant
s'inscrire dans la vision du président
de la République d'une France fière
d'elle-même je veux vous assurer ici du
soutien et de la confiance des députés
renaissance pour terminer mon propos
monsieur le pr
ministre je veux vous lancer cet appel
le même que Danton fit jadis à la
tribune de l'audace encore de l'audace
toujours de l'audace et la France est
sauvée je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président